I'm wondering do you think that a
director should edit their own film or
are they too close to it is it to UM
ocean or for them to really some people
say that's when you have the ultimate
control isn't that editing it's true and
it's true well I think I think by the
time a director has directed a film the
director is closer to it than anyone
else and also because the director shot
the film the director you know framed
scene by scene the film that in general
if an editor comes in and tries to do
something other than what was in the
mind of the director it's a little like
something that got created by committee
but mostly you know we have an editor
working while the director is shooting
and you know and there is an editor
other than the director mostly and so
that by the time the film is finished
shooting and shortly thereafter there is
a cut of the film that we can kind of
look at and see you know did the movie
get shot did we hit there's something
some glaring something glaring that's
missing that we maybe didn't even think
about while the script was being
developed or while the you know while we
were in pre-production or production or
sometimes the reverse we see things that
are really not needed and it's really
sad because you went to all the expense
and all the trouble of shooting things
and they just they don't move the story
forward for some reason so I think it's
certainly important for the director to
be in the editing room I think that the
the editor during the shoot edits
according to what the directors notes
are in the script notes so yeah I think
in a way the director is always a kind
of an editor
you